2022 fue un año marcado por redadas
israelíes casi diarias en discordania
ocupada pero ninguna como la vivida hoy
en jenning que ha durado tres horas y ha
sido tildada por los palestinos de
masacre por su elevado número de Muertos
el ejército israelí entró en este campo
de refugiados mucho más blindado de lo
habitual con vehículos armados
francotiradores drones y fuerzas
encubiertas todo con el fin de arrestar
a miembros de la yihat islámica
Palestina según el ejército en este
operativo ha matado a tres militantes
pero entre los fallecidos reportados por
el Ministerio de salud palestino también
hay una mujer de 60 años y más de una
decena de heridos de hecho los oficiales
de salud palestinos han denunciado que
los soldados israelíes bloquearon el
paso de las ambulancias incluso les
dispararon en el parabrisas y también
lanzaron gases lacrimógenos en la
entrada de un hospital pediátrico a modo
de protesta cisjordania se ha declarado
un cuadro general con cierre de
comercios como en la ciudad de nablus y
otras manifestaciones como la vista en
ramala si bien la mayor advertencia
procede la yihad islámica Palestina que
ha subrayado que si las incursiones
persisten en yening los enfrentamientos
no se van a limitar a este campo de
refugiados Y es que con la violencia de
hoy en lo que va de 2023 ya hay más de
un palestino muerto por día a manos del
ejército de Israel que ahora está bajo
su gobierno más extremista de
ultraderecha y que ha dejado claro una
mayor represión contra los palestinos y
una mayor expansión de su control en los
territorios ocupados